Hello, everyone.
Hello, hello.
Oh, I'm sorry for starting late today.
There were so many things to do.
So many things to do.
Oh, okay, wait.
Did I save my James Bond sound?
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
Oh, but I'm not prepared.
I don't know.
I woke up at like 11 a.m.
I was, okay.
So I...
won't there's no tldr i'll start from the beginning so um i
might have okay no i will do give you tldr sorry my mind is
like all over the place right now i had like i was given
like 800 different information today and then my mind is
like it's like i had a little nuclear bomb in my head
because i was just fed like 800 different thousand things uh
information in my head uh i need to do Anyway, TLDR, I was
only awake for three hours in 24 hours.
I was only awake for like three hours because I was, I like,
okay, so I was super jet lagged.
You guys didn't know I tweeted up yesterday.
We were supposed to do a watch alarm thing.
We were supposed to do a watch alarm thing yesterday because
I was like, I want to use my rest day to do it.
I couldn't I my jet lag was hitting me super hard so I went
to bed around like eight like whenever I posted that tweet
be like geez guys I'm not gonna do the watch along that like
today I'm just gonna sleep I'm just gonna I have jet lag
because I think it was like eight or nine a.m.
that I I finally went to bed and I woke up at 7 p.m.
but I wasn't hungry at all like I didn't eat anything at all
Until 10 p.m.
So I was just like, and I went back, and I went back and
just stayed in my bed and marrying it in my bed, which was a
bad idea.
Wait, I think like at first, no.
I think at like, I woke up at first at five.
I woke up at five.
And then I was like, and then I went back to sleep.
I was like, I'm so...
tired but I think that was my body telling me something at
because I was like 5 p.m.
I was like I don't want to move at all or am I so tired even
I didn't even drink water at all I was just like I was like
oh and then I didn't hydrate at all I didn't eat anything
and I I fell back asleep I fell back asleep I wasn't even
thirsty I should have been dehydrated but I wasn't and um
and then I went back to sleep and I think I woke up at like
8 p.m.
or 9 p.m.
and I was like oh my god I'm pain and then I went to the
bathroom and then I was just like
blood blood everywhere you know like when the light is on
and then you see like a crime scene and i was like oh no oh
no i went to the bathroom i was like i was super groggy i
sat on the toilet the light is finally on i looked down and
i'm like
and then because like you know okay for the and then so
you're like no turkey why would you tell us you it's your
time of the month you mean a time of the year because i i
haven't had my period for seven months i know at some point
i should have been like i should see a doctor but that was
like i'll do that next time but then next time never
happened and then obviously that should have been a health
concern but i was just like it'll come eventually like yep
yeah it's sort of kind of Concerning that it took seven
months because I'm super I'm irregular, but never that
irregular.
Yeah That's definitely yeah Yeah, so here's a red thing bro.
It's symbolic cyber.
Thank you for the akasupa.
Thank you.
Thank you I I was just like it'll happen eventually, but
then like it never happened and then so I was like This is
getting a little concerning.
I even like was like I was like googling I was like How many
months is it too long?
And then they're like, you should see a doctor.
I was like, I should see a doctor.
Anyway, so I was very stressed out.
I still am.
But I think Korea offset my stress a bit.
And then finally, my body was like, oh, she's on vacation.
It's time.
Little do they know I'm still stressed.
I should I think Korea like helped helped me there because I
was less stressed out I was in Korea but then I think like
but like I'm still stressed I came back and I'm still
stressed but I think it like gave me some time for my body
being like I think she's I think it's over yeah it's like my
body was like I think it's over I think she quit her job um
Yeah, so that's because it's always been irregular, but it's
never like it's never been that bad before and at some point
I was just going to be like, okay, if it hits like X amount
of months, I should see a doctor.
But anyway, so I'm not I'm not used to it at all.
Like I'm not it's been so long since I've had my period.
I've done my bot.
I'm like I'm trying to remember what it was like to be a
woman.
I'm trying to I'm trying to rip up from what it was like to
be a woman I was like oh yeah because I forgot I forgot what
crafts were like and then I forgot it's it's not great it's
not I'm like oh and I was so tired too like for those who
are unfortunately who do not you know have to do not pee out
their blood uh
you get really really tired when it's the time of the year
when you get so tired so i was like basically like i didn't
i was not productive at all and then I was like there's no
way I'd sleep even more but also I had like cravings for ice
cream too so I I ordered like two different types of ice
cream at Dairy Queen um anyway so I ate my food and then I
like I think I like yeah like I said I I went to bed at 4 a
.m but I was alive for like three hours so I was marinating
in the bed for a while before I got up got my PC to like
watch and then with my dairy queen ice cream um and then
went back to sleep and then i was like oh man i slept so
much there's no way there's no way i sleep even more and i i
literally passed out to like i passed out till like 9 a.m
but i was so tired i was so tired i still kept sleeping i
was like I'll just set up a alarm and then alarm went off
and I was like I'll set up another alarm and then alarm went
up and I was like I'll set up another alarm and it was 11 a
.m.
and I was like I should get up I should really get up
because I'm not didn't make my waiting room didn't do
anything productive at all and I was still so fucking tired
I was like I know I was only awake for three hours within 24
hours and I was still so tired because my body has seven
months of period blood In me right now.
That's trying to like reject itself.
Turns out.
I'm sorry if it's really gross.
I'm so sorry.
I have to break it to you guys.
That your bro's a woman.
But.
But it's.
My body is getting used to being a woman again.
It's it's it's rough right now.
It's so rough.
Because I forgot what it was like.
I was I for.
I forgot what that was like, guys.
I'm just like, oh my God.
Why did it have to remind me?
I was actually enjoying it.
I was actually enjoying the fact that it's not healthy.
It's not healthy.
I know.
But it was seven months of bliss.
You know, it was...
It was...
It's not healthy, but it was seven months of ignorant bliss.
you were a pro for seven months um duck thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you double and give it to future
doki doki from seven months ago and six months ago double it
double it that just kept going on it was fun while it lasted
oh my gosh well you listen for chat thank you thank you ever
seen yes i have and i talked about it i said it doesn't
matter for me it's so irregular like i've had once ones
where it's like two to three months or two months sometimes
it's regular it's just so you're seven months is my record
though i will say that is my record right now i hope i hope
i don't break it
my fruit of freedom it's god yeah it's not i hope it doesn't
again oh my god um what else what but yes that basically and
then when I woke up not okay by the way my manager has been
able to reach me for like two three days so I had three days
of work to be like I mean three or four days since I came
back from Korea like then he's like we have to be in a car
right now and I was like, I just pooped.
He's like, he's like, I'm awake now.
And then he's like, all right, we gotta get in the call.
And then I didn't say anything for like 30 plus minutes.
And then I replied back, I just pooped.
And he's like, okay.
This is vital information.
He's like, we need to talk.
We have so much stuff to do.
And like, ha ha, I just came back from the bathroom.
Here's my update.
This is critical to the dokey bird lore.
I'm so professional.
And then we got in a call and it was like, and I'm like, ah,
ah, who would have known running away from my
responsibilities was a bad thing.
I don't know.
Who would have have done and he's like boom and I
legitimately at the end he kept going and I was like I was
just like I literally was like ah and he's like okay we'll
go over this tomorrow and I was like okay I literally went
ah because he kept going there was more stuff yeah and he
was just like yeah curse you pastoki how could you do this
to me i would pastoki do this he was like i will we'll go
over this tomorrow because i legitimately just started like
ah um i had to clean my room it was bad well by cleaning i
had to put stuff in the garbage bag it was bad so that's why
we were 30 minutes late it was just a lot of stuff to do it
was just yeah who would have thought if you go missing for
three to four days things start piling up and then later
today there's just so much stuff to do today i just realized
my channel after like after like like x amount like five
plus months of zero collabs i did like four collabs back to
back to back to back on the channel i was like looking at my
youtube channel i was like oh my god it's just all collab
i'm just i'm just like fucking did a speed run of like all
the collab debt that i didn't do it was like what it was
literally four collabs in a row and i have another collab
tonight too so let me make a waiting room for that as well
you welcome to tomato fire welcome welcome but i had so much
stuff to do uh let's see the last uh this week in this week
in general there was just a lot of things being like on my
schedule and everything um unfortunately i cornered and
finished the watch a lot but we'll do it next week i
legitimately could not fit anything more like i cannot i
cannot fit anything more anymore like i sneaked in another
collab and then for today uh with i'm mouse rin and i'm a
lead and i at 11 p.m Yeah, the thing's not happening and
everything happening at once.
And then tomorrow, I have a convention tomorrow in the
morning.
And then I'm on record today after that.
And then Sunday may be a sponsor stream.
I don't know yet.
I'm not sure.
My manager was like, do you want to do this?
Because I'm going to say no.
Because it's in two days.
And then I was like, Sunday is my free day.
Well, I can put it on Sunday.
And you're like, are you sure?
And I was just like, yeah.
Yeah, that's future doki's problem.
Yeah, but money, though.
He's like, are you sure?
I was like, yeah.
Future doki can worry about that.
Why is past doki so mean the future doki?
I'm going to double it and give it to the next doki.
Alright guys, let me make my waiting room real quick For the
other, the other sponsor Alright, not the other, sorry, the
other collab Okay Um Let me make that real quick Which one
was it called?
It's called Alright, let me find the thumbnail for it
Burgling Nones Pastohi is a menace.
Past and present, Doki.
There's so many events still.
Oh my gosh.
So next week, I'll be doing two tournaments next week, back
to back.
I'll be doing the Overwatch tournament and the Capcom Cup
tournament.
Or not Capcom Cup, sorry.
New Challengers, Capcom Street Fighter tournament all on the
same day.
Because I hate myself.
They even were like, are you sure you want to do the
Overwatch one?
Was like, are you sure you want to do both because uh
because like um your teammates chose was supposed to do the
overwatch one as well but they chose the street fighter are
you sure and i was like yeah they even gave me a free a free
out they're like are you sure because some of your teammates
in the some of the players that were uh in the street
fighter tournament decided to choose to do one instead of
two uh do you also want to do that and i was like no too
i would okay to be fair it was it's more i i was very i'm
very greedy i am very greedy person because i haven't done
an overwatch tournament in so long and it was like i you
know i haven't done it in so long and i really really really
wanted to do an overwatch tournament just Because, like,
it's been so fucking long since I played Overwatch in a
tournament setting.
And I just, I was just really craving it.
So I'm being a little too greedy.
Just a little bit.
I have not practiced Overwatch at all.
I have practiced Tree Fighter, though.
I have practiced Tree Fighter.
I'm still gonna get my ass kicked.
But I have practiced for it.
So, um, checkmate.
all right let me make the uh let me make the collab room
real quick where is oh my gosh i forgot i'm a lease lee and
lee and lie all right what is it called get get noomed all
right no mean what was that quote called i'm not a goblin i
am not a gnome what does he actually say oh hello there i'm
not gonna gnaw i'm not a gnawbland i'm a gnome and you've
been a gnome i'm playing my for those who don't know i've
talked about it before but uh i love that meme i'm a gnome
i'm not like a gnome i'm not like a gnawbland i'm a gnome
That's right.
Get domed.
All right, let me download this real quick.
Podogre Doki outfit one.
Thank you for the super chat, Juan George.
Thank you.
Oh, hi.
Let's see.
Let me finish this real quick.
Burgling gnomes.
Uh.
There we go.
And then there's a thumbnail.
I know there isn't.
And then it will be at 11 p.m.
Thank God I'm in the West Coast.
Thank fucking God.
All right.
Waiting room up.
Waiting room's going to be up very soon.
I have like 8 million tabs right now.
I need to really get rid of some of these.
I'm all over the place.
Oh, I am all over the place.
Let me see.
What was my sound settings for James by?
Oh, I hope I saved it.
I did.
Thank God.
Okay.
I did save it.
At least I have that.
I got a little worried there.
All right.
Nice.
I think I got everything.
Just want to be sure I got everything, guys.
Just want to be sure.
sec.
All right.
We're gonna game very soon.
Give me a sec, guys.
It's my birthday today.
No need to sing all-in for my birthday.
It was for you to get some fucking rest today.
Thank you for the magenta soup for it.
Thank you.
Don't worry, I'll still give you a song.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday Day dear Fowler.
Yeah.
Happy birthday to you.
Yippee.
All right.
It is time.
Let me make sure I have.
Oh, I just realized DVR was on.
Whoops.
Oh, wait.
No, that wasn't it.
That was on me.
No, it wasn't.
It was not on.
I was looking at the collab room.
there you go there you go sorry i'm messy i'm starting i'm
deleting my tabs right now all right tabs deleting starting
now let's see uh i'm gonna start deleting my tabs so i have
more stuff so obviously i won't be super overwhelmed today i
forgot all the controls which is oh which i mean to be fair
like of course i'm gonna forget all the controls it's been
like almost two weeks of not playing so today is gonna be
fun i'll just know how to shoot things that's it uh
okay but there was something i wanted to talk about but i'm
trying to remember what it was before i begin oh yeah did
you guys hear uh they grew t-rex skin you guys hear that and
they're selling it for like 500 grand 500k grand do you
think with five gifted chips they could thank you yeah some
luxury brand grew like t-rex skin leather skin and made it
into a handbag and now they're auctioning it off you guys
hear about that's like crazy yeah it's happening yeah no
that sounds sick Yeah, they replicated the cellular data for
T-Rex skin.
Yeah, and now they're auctioning.
I don't know when they're auctioning off, but it's going to
be auctioned off for like $500,000.
That's taking the world we live in now.
Sounds like bullshit.
One last concert guest get announced today.
talk more about it later whenever it's tweeted out it'll be
finally announced today because that means you guys want to
know why guys some mayhaps streaming tickets will be
announced soon too whoa i will not confirm or deny it i will
not confirm nor deny the other announcement
All right, let's boot up the game finally.
Uh, there you go.
But that, the other tickets that has not been confirmed or
not, that will not confirm or deny, that may or may not be
being sold this week or later this week or next week.
um I will not confirm or deny it
um oh I'm preloading shaders give me a sec it's gonna take a
while oh my god wave of tiredness just hit me just now oh my
god oh just a wave of like I'm so oh my god oh my god my
body's playing catch up of seven months my body is just like
here's every symptom that's ever existed get her
oh my god
oh my god is it the shaders it's the shaders guys I'm
compiling the shaders I'm back it's just shader things
I'm here I'm here guys I'm just compiling shaders right now
all right here we go what the fuck is there's new policies
what happened what the fuck happened all right don't ask me
again all right let's resume game I should forgot what
happened.
What did I?
Oh, I broke into the thing.
I remember now.
I broke in.
Back, baby.
Oh, wait.
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna see how I can be doing this real quick.
Give me a sec, guys.
Sorry.
Work message real quick.
Like I said, there's a million things.
There you go.
I'm ready.
Shit, how do I play this game?
Seems we've run out of elevator.
Well, the bridge to the perch is only three floors up.
Okay.
I see you get a move on before Roger recovers and you dig
yourself in even deeper.
Let's go.
I'm glad like, apparently, there's a big rivals tournament
right now.
I'm glad.
I didn't get asked to join it, but I think if I did.
I would have actually combusted.
I was asked for that to hear it, but I'm glad I wasn't asked
for it because I do not think I would be okay.
I...
No, I was then like, I do not have time.
I care to join you.
Right now, this week is a lot.
This week is a lot.
Lock tight.
And we don't have executive clearance.
We don't.
Lateral thinking from here on out.
Alright, we gotta grab clearance.
Get to the stairs.
Yeah.
There's a lot of stuff to look forward to.
A lot of fun things to look forward to.
So I just want to make sure I have enough stuff to go
around.
A lot of fun events, a lot of fun collabs.
A lot of fun sponsors.
Lots of fun.
A lot of fun stuff.
up i'll check the perimeter let me know if you find
something we'll do
let's see doesn't mean i won't be in another rivals
tournament though but at least it's not at least it's not
today that's the fine world is making the first move that's
a fun everything here's what's happening now what the fuck
do i do played his hand now he's doing all in his
considerable power to shut us down which includes calling in
a favor from his friend the foreign secretary okay right
will force M's hand to axe us or he'll pull her funding
between the two of us and the future of the double O program
she will have no choice so come morning we will be
discredited and disavowed oh no so unless you want to
consult bavmar about career opportunities i suggest really
bond my fault i keep i'm sorry sorry i was so into the i was
tripped wait no i ended this dialogue i did what okay what
happens in the morning what happens in the morning so so
come morning we will be discredited and disavowed so unless
you want to consult bavmar about career opportunities no i
meant like the tournament for today there's a Big rivals
tournament going on today.
And I was like, at first I was like, oh, I didn't get asked
to join.
But now I'm like, oh, thank God.
This week is not, like, if it was any other week, great.
But this week, there's just so many things.
This week was, this week was a lot.
Okay, sorry, I got another work, man.
all right what are you yeah i was just like there was just
so much stuff bond i swear to god oh you guys are talking
about the other tournament the other turn that other rivals
tournament is not is like in how when is that one that one's
in two oh shit oh that one's in two weeks now i'm talking
about the one for this week i don't think they started for
the tournament in two weeks yet.
This looks like a way up.
This one?
The other big one.
What is he saying?
Oh, he wants me to jump up.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my gosh.
Let's do it.
I'm up.
Let's get this over with.
Now I'm talking about the Sina one.
The... There was like so much...
Oh, I feel like a lot of these tournaments now there's so
much drama about their one the luna one that's happening
today there was like a lot of drama about it um because like
people were like oh why didn't you ask like because like but
it's like this term was clearly geared towards like creators
who don't play rivals like the main tournament just because
they want people they want more attention from non-rival
streamers so that because the viewers would be like oh I've
never seen that game.
I've never seen you play that game before.
So they want more publicity geared towards people who don't
play rivals.
But a lot of creators got really mad because they're like,
oh, there should be more tournaments for the rivals creators
because it was a huge prize pool.
Which is understandable.
I get it.
Am I supposed to go up here?
Oh no, I'm going to that window.
Let's see.
All right.
in where am i supposed to go now i'm in but also what do i
do wait did i finish breaking into that other office i just
bet you could use the ledge to reach the balcony yeah but i
want to see if i if they have anything i can like take you
know any money any what's down there
what's my what was my eagle vision again i don't remember
My bond vision.
What's my bond vision, guys?
Oh, no.
Oh, it's all, yeah.
There you go.
My bond vision.
I was going to say, there must be, like, items or something.
Like, see out of here.
Because I'm supposed to do something.
I'm not supposed to be here.
but I just want to be sure if I'm...
Oh, there's some guy in the bathroom.
Yeah.
Oh, God.
That guy okay?
Oh.
No, that guy's not okay.
Hey, sir.
How do I make him leave?
Oh, distract.
Oh.
that distracted him wait i guess it didn't it's not
concerned my stomach oh do you mind someone's in here a
little privacy i got an office key oh okay oh oh he dropped
it he was so up
oh was that him was that the guy fucking I don't remember
what past Doki did.
I'm not gonna lie.
I
Did not I guess past Doki did drug him After careful
consideration Well, what's up with my face that oh shit.
I oh Shit whoops
I did everything whoops what did I do?
do okay i didn't even notice i was so absorbed with kicking
stuff which one was this oh i fixed all my i fixed my face
guys all right let me fix let me fix that i didn't even
realize i had that on all right give me a sec guys all the
buttons oh yeah 100 so let me turn that off real quick let
me turn that off might have too many buttons guys just a
little too many okay yeah that should be fine there you go
i'm back we resume game all right after careful i keep i
think it fits your mental state right now thank you for chat
allan thank you thank you after careful consideration has
been decided that one on invitation to join one of the elite
dev teams at our r d facility is a private matter will not
be openly announced at friday's meetings in the monthly
newsletter is up to each employee whether they want to share
the happy news with their team or not this is to prevent
toxic interdepartmental rivalry and resentment i appreciate
you understanding okay nice
professional yeah i'm a professional streamer if you like to
say that although i got the key i don't even remember
drugging that guy good job pastyoki he wasn't needing it i
say bonk kicking a man when he's lying down on all fours
technically let's hope he's not the kind of man to hold a
grudge a decline from the application from the blade club
london's most exclusive private car club.
The one Robert Finch.
I did it, guys.
Oh, oh, I remembered a wooden spoon booby press from
Cambridge Law.
I remember because I was so bad at lying.
See?
Pastoki had a plan all along.
Guys, I was purposely bad at lying, guys.
I was purposely bad at lying so he would do so he would drug
him and then i'd get the card see i had a plan it was all it
was all calculated i knew if he drugged him i would get the
card
good job pastoki you knew what's up for current doki a
magazine on marlon architecture featuring an article about
the web industry building in his daughter's office this
around the world today i don't know if i'll be doing long
stream for james bond today just because of how fucked up i
feel i haven't had food yet by the way um the clean where we
both have access to every room on the floor and may be
redirected to specific location using the control panel
situated throughout the floors might not be a long stream
today maybe i should eat something.
You know, I'll grab something to eat right now.
I have food in the fridge.
Give me a sec.
I'll grab something.
I'm back.
I have some leftovers.
Jumbo Nikki!
Alright.
I need to eat that now before, like, later tonight.
Because usually, like, that shit sucks after it's in the
fridge too long.
Hmm.
Let's go.
that ego vision
i what reached it okay i was gonna say where the fuck is my
door toggle in the books m is a member of the bay blades
club that finch was directed from bomb was once invented to
get a member to stop shooting at card but he was a secret so
it became a whole oh what the fuck i'll be fine And yes,
thank you, a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Are there any more collectibles around?
Locked.
Fancy that.
I'm starting to think we're not welcome.
Let's poke about.
Simon, there was a favor and take Chessman for achievement
for a pint later, will you?
I found a poor chap sobbing in the cupboard after a French
toringer in a new asshole over a botched lunch order.
I know he's been a twat, but he's one of them.
much now you have a theory m.i6 was willing to ignore the
risks because web got results but with thea what's to stop
him from rigging the next election or worse first time but
in my experience the motive is always simple and almost
always sorted bringing the next election i'm pretty sure the
next election has already been rigged i
don't think they have to worry about that anything else is
there anybody in the bathroom i want to be sure if there's
any extra loot i can grab at this point i have to compete on
who gets the rig first anybody on the other side oh there is
i could do that and then kick it
okay the guy looks like he's drugged
what's in here
I will say the security here is pretty bad I'm not gonna lie
for a tech company the security is not great I think the AI
might have been vibe coded I'm pretty sure the AI was vibe
coded here thanks for that this is a reminder that you're
not to discuss classified projects on the tube and a taxi at
the pub or any other public semi-public or otherwise
non-secure location even the smallest breach may cause
severe financial harm to the company our partners and
shareholders would not ruin to report p of the einberg
incident if the doubt whether to speak or don't thank you
like where are the secure where's the cameras stand on our
brand new equipment brand new equipment boxes when a clean
event all right
like where are the cat where are the cameras
dressed for success oh all right i guess i take it
you've ral's sleeping beauty in there not to worry i'll tuck
him back in
It's like, what the fuck?
Oi, who did this?
Show yourself.
Uh, oh, wait, he's resistant.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
He doesn't know!
That's right.
What about a rude awakening?
Yeah, he's like, it must be in the bathrooms.
Or am I?
You might be resistant.
to my gadgets but no one's ever resistant to the fist all
right let's get some wine oh okay okie-roam on the nose this
is oh yeah the door
what uh does he have a card sir did you drop a card no Oh,
he did it.
Security is currently moving to a server room to toss out
all the servers of evidence.
Think of the Super Chat MVS.
Thank you.
You see, I called to grab the door.
Please repair the door's only lock.
He had a moment.
It was a classified documents are stolen.
I tried to find the key!
Oh, I got the hack.
Oh, never mind.
JK, I got it.
So what's your take then?
On Sir Nicholas's dark secret.
Well, while he monologues, I'll finish my sushi.
My jumbo nigeri!
Hush money alone would feed a small nation.
I bet 009 found out about something.
Figured it will be his golden ticket back into where my six
is good graces.
So he had to die at all costs.
See?
Simple.
Very.
Mm-hmm.
It's open.
No.
Figures.
What's the plan?
Yeah.
Well, let's see.
What do we do?
Okay, I have an idea.
I'm the brawn.
He the brave.
Don't tell me the old pro needs a timeout.
Tactical pause.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, sorry.
I guess you don't want...
You don't want me to be on your left side.
You're right-handed, I guess.
It's strange, don't you think?
Join me, but join me on the right.
I'm genuinely sorry about what happened tonight.
You liked you, Bong.
You got in his way.
That's the world you're in now.
Half this job is doing something you'd rather not.
Sooner you learn that, the better.
Never married?
Mrs. Greenway, I take it.
And why the sudden interest?
Am I dying?
Or, um, Mr. Greenway?
She was a special liaison with the treasury.
After nightfall, I was in a dark place.
And she couldn't handle.
Oh.
She took a job overseas.
Long story, not nearly short enough.
On the upside, you get a monogrammed fountain pen in case
you fail to die young.
True.
You must take the rough with the smooth.
would you ever forgive 009 we'd never have known about web
if it wasn't for 009 I think if things had gone differently
you would have forgiven him he was a traitor that doesn't
answer the question you don't get to wipe the slate clean
fact is Reese was a bad apple and I should have seen it is
this doom Yowie before like assume nothing trust no older
men sounds like no way to live splendid way to stay alive
though Why did you come back?
So why did you come back to the program?
Because they ask.
We're civil servants, Bond.
We go where we're needed.
And I'm sure running out the clock behind a desk on the
eighth floor, writing reports while slowly mummifying from
boredom and nothing to do with it.
One doesn't exclude the other.
Well, good chat.
Back to it.
What?
According to the floor plan, that lounge next door connects
to the other side.
find a way in you'll be able to double back and unlock the
doors sounds simple enough the what reach the lounge okay
wait sorry the what instructions unclear a little bit what
did he want me to do take this fuck this nobody's here
anyway i gotta max up my stuff anyway a resume on dr.
Selena's 10 was a note from recruitment top candidates head
to the be WBE like go to the lounge and do this then do that
and I'm like excuse me what did you want me to do okay oh
okay I just need a how do I get to that other side of the
balcony look away across where stone is right in the face oh
the tree oh you're
just gonna sit there okay all right i guess i'll do all the
work okay this is a swim i see it do not climb over little
does he know i don't know how to read all right mvs thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you fun fact double o
has a mandatory retirement age of 45 after that you go to
death studio and stuff i mean it would make sense at that
age you're just gonna be like i mean you'll be old your body
ain't in what it's used to be you know you can't do like
double cartwheels there's not you know there's like you know
at some point excuse me do you need something at some point
you're gonna run out a skin for bullets to go through.
I was practicing parkour.
Thanks.
We'll do.
You know, just some little parkour.
I swear, this wasn't here last week.
I just put down a deposit for a new place.
Um...
The company isn't sure to have to the eyeballs.
Uh-huh.
Now he's a little sick.
Where's he off to?
I have enough love.
Wouldn't be funny if I...
Hello?
Oh, am I gonna start beating people up?
I don't want any trouble.
Do not reach for anything.
Alright, um...
Oh, God!
Oh, I forgot how to fight!
Oh, shit!
Guys, how do I fight again?
I don't remember!
Situatious process of being contained.
I forgot how to use my fist.
Oh, I don't remember any of the moves.
Okay, give me a sec.
Yes, guys, one of the controls.
Yes, guys.
Oh, God, okay.
I'm back.
Okay.
Strike.
Hold shift for charge.
Okay.
Perry was Q.
It was Q.
Alright.
Grab was E.
Okay.
Alright.
I have figured it out now.
Okay.
E.
Q.
Q and E.
Alright.
I can do this again.
Hello.
Who are you?
Hey.
We weren't ready for this now.
Take it easy.
Yeah.
I'm not here to fight.
That's right.
I'm here to contain the situation.
It's not a fight.
It's a containment.
That's different.
Guys, it's different.
I swear this wasn't here last week.
I don't know if I...
I just put that in the box.
Guys, do you think that was a bad idea?
You think that's...
Oh, shit.
Oh,
I should not have thrown.
Maybe I should not have thrown that cup.
Maybe.
Okay, okay.
Take this.
I'm serious now.
For real.
I'm serious.
Serious.
Take it easy.
I don't want any trouble.
You move.
You're getting hurt.
All right.
Let me contain this situation.
And then...
And then things will be okay.
For real.
I swear this wasn't here last week.
Oh.
Hey.
Oh, thank God he had to check out the trash.
Thank God he had to check out the trash real quick.
Very convenient.
Alright.
All right, I'm just gonna contain this real quick.
I got it.
Look, there's some budget cuts, okay?
Some of the security guards had to also work part-time as
janitors.
What the fuck?
Why yellow?
Oh, wait, I could explode that.
Actually, I could not explode that.
I could just walk past this, right?
Best security that money can buy.
Truly the best security.
They might have been that boat hired.
I will not doubt it.
They may have been that boat hired to be security guards.
Can I just open it?
No, I can't.
I have to hack it.
Sorry for the weight.
I have company.
I see.
There you go.
I know that you're out of place.
Impressive.
I wonder if there...
Like, is nobody in the security camera room right now?
Like, just seeing me just fucking, like, crouch walking the
entire building?
Like a thief in the night.
Why Bond will make a spy of you yet?
This is one security guy.
Just seeing me crouch walking everything.
reports this.
Looks like we're stuck.
Don't be too sure.
Oh, there's the little cleaner man.
Hello.
Bye, little cleaner man.
Cleaning robot.
You never actually planned to pack it in tonight, did you?
I had to tread carefully.
There's only a handful of operators in the world with the
chops and resources that infiltrate MI6, Bond.
Simplest answer.
locked down systems engaged you couldn't be that easy we
need visibility
the best spy in the world well perhaps some of these offices
are connected on it anyway you were saying about pretending
to pocket yeah yeah what were you saying i had to tread
carefully there's only a hand of operators in the world with
the chops and yeah i even looked at this guy simplest answer
it's someone already inside you suspected web the idea did
cross my mind how does he know our every move in advance
ockham's razor it's literally the ai it's literally the pc
got any suspects i suspect everyone well anyone who hasn't
been shot at yet okay let's grab this though i need these
there yeah it's gotta refuel real quick he's literally i'm
pretty sure it's the computer the ai thing greenway give me
a hand with this coming hey doesn't this all feel a little
too easy but literally i just stepped through the laser
security and they're like locked down and then We're still
here?
Where the fuck is everybody?
Including you.
Trust me.
When the enemy stops underestimating you, that's when you
start to worry.
More pearls of wisdom.
Let me get a pen.
Like, shouldn't the room be like infiltrated by now by 80
men?
I don't want to go in here.
We'll see.
There's some papers to read.
Um, is he still available?
Senior crisis manager.
Dare say she'll be seeking new challenges.
Yeah, I was gonna say someone's gonna get fired soon.
Expensive face.
From Columbia University blind.
This person might get fired soon.
Oh, hey, nice.
I got an office toy.
Yoink.
Blueprints of web HQ.
Surveyless pictures.
What?
Oh my god.
It's turned into a heist movie.
Where am I?
It's this way.
Like my little souvenir.
I'm walking as fast as I can.
Oh, I guess he doesn't want to go through the events.
He's too good for that.
A Hampshire police report on the death of Damien's mother.
Damien Webb's office.
Damien Webb in 2004.
Suicide by prescription painkillers.
indicate the report has been studied obsessively oh he
thinks it's an inside job what's this a chardinian where the
motos go a long way back with the merino twins an elite
mercenary group believed to offer one of the most dangerous
hot zones yemen
emerging biomedical company saxonornic for some chemical
compound yeah that's
everything skin care he's a stark raving lunatic but he does
have gorgeous he have a true groomer oh he's a groomer let's
catch him with upgraded danious warrior mask all right open
sesame
the clean robots have access to every room and may be
redirected specific location using the control panel uh the
door opens when electric sensors detect and approaching no
human Oh, okay, I just hacked the robot.
Should be that easy.
Got everything.
Is there anything else in that room?
Oh, there's another thing about this Isola.
I think that's everything.
Where's the robot at?
Oh, there it is.
It's right through here.
Get over here, little guy.
I need to hack you.
How do I...
How do I get over there?
Where are the other robots?
Okay.
Am I supposed to be here?
Or will that robot come over here?
Come over here, little guy!
I gotta hack you!
Oh, I think I have to...
Is there another little guy?
Maybe there's another...
you'll hear that miss.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, hey.
Isol has been laying it on rather thick.
A stock photo?
It's not even her actual dog?
When will it end?
When will these lies end?
Not even her real dog.
Her entire identity is a lie.
We'll get closer.
She's a larper.
Oh my god, come on!
Come on, little guy!
Oh hey.
Nice.
Well played.
How did we ever live without a queue watch?
Oh my god, refuel?
That's convenient.
Alright, this way.
yeah we go this way
all right that should be easy all right you there get hacked
come on come on little guy I gotta start hacking you oh wait
does he follow me oh oh never mind he is not following me
what's your job like what's your purpose come on get over
here i need your help coast is clear is treacherous.
Why would you say a thing like that?
Alright.
This was the...
Oh, wait, that was pretty easy.
Maybe it's open.
The gate is right upstairs.
Let's find out.
Alright, I'm ready.
Come on.
Come on, old man.
Well, lock pickings out of the question.
I'm medically sealed.
and blast resistant by the look of it we need clearance or
we're not getting through i do love a good i told you so i
never would have thought all right house should be right
upstairs upstairs all right gotta go to his penthouse did
they come to your home worse they came to my pub oh the game
was on the telly and i noticed these lads they were in club
colors but they never once glanced at the game I slipped out
the window in the men's room only to find the actual kill
team waiting in the alleyway And there's the lesson never
overestimate yourself got a bit hairy after that if the
sling hadn't thrown them I might have actually needed your
help.
Yeah, don't mention it.
Oh, you want to smoke up your ass bond Join the Americans
All right.
Oh my god, the underestimated guy in the sling
There's like no way, there's no way this guy can take on all
of us.
Oh, oh.
What happened here?
We're not the only gate crushers.
Someone had a little too much to drink.
Come morning in where she wasn't.
Does he have a key card?
No, they took it.
But look, there's a dozer on the other side.
A dozer.
So all we need to get through the door is get through the
door.
Leave it to me.
Oh my god.
Someone had too much to drink here.
Sleeping on the job.
Oh, he's not gonna like yet.
What's this?
We're optimistic.
Future is driven by a desire to reduce human error in the
global scale through technology and AI.
At this point, this isn't even human error.
For an AI company.
You know.
I don't think this is human error no more.
Not a very good AI company.
Definitely very vibe coded.
Tonight we celebrate the history of web industry.
But merely...
The fact that it's not just us crashing the building.
It's another group also crashing the building.
They let two groups of intruders in.
Just like that.
We're more than, let's push for a better, safer future,
through precision and perfection.
We can introduce risk and minimize damage yet.
I want us to aim higher.
What risk and minimize?
What risk and minimize damage?
Was this generated by ChatGPD?
Oh, it's another tree.
Oh, all right.
Hard to reach.
Yeah, should have asked you for a grapple gun.
Are you thinking what I'm thinking?
Yes.
At least those pills have kicked in.
Oh.
Is he gonna...
Is he gonna, like, give me a little...
A little boosty boost?
We'll have to climb this up.
Where is he?
Sure thing.
Alright.
Dally.
Oh my god, with one hand.
Usually you need two to brace.
That guy's secretly jacked.
Eh.
Bolt.
Yeah, the guy has a 10-pack.
The 20th century magnate.
All he needs now is a top hat and monocle.
Why are the books two meters above the ground?
So the very top people can also read.
I mean...
So they can also be...
So they are inclusive.
If it's not.
If it's not that.
Then what is it?
Why is this way?
What about the short people?
Making you get asked the tall people for a little boost.
To grab a book.
And the short people can also.
work out you must be this tall to read exactly it's called
um it's called discrimination have you not worked in the
company before something you're not telling me bomb I
suspect you'll know soon enough
another perch door also sealed the lobby's on the right
almost there we're almost there oh my gosh this is just the
hall filled we where are the cameras where are where are the
cameras here she a friend of yours how do you know it's a
her well i do now gotta be eight feet in this workplace or
die actually where the fuck are the security cameras
in here at
least they have AI cleaners yeah those are the little things
very clean at least they can make this place very clean oh
there she is the fake French girl thank God we should really
stop meeting like this you blew my cover I had to excuse me
man you must be this tall to read do he stretch his neck all
right thank you for the super chat thank you thank you give
me one reason why we shouldn't feed you to security what
security there's only two of you and second I can get you
into the perch oh yeah she's is is Ola she's the one with a
fake dog I forgot her name to here it's been two weeks I'm
not gonna lie it's a bit involved I could use a helping hand
or three go on time is of the essence james get up to the
penthouse whole timer with me i'll explain on the way all
right oh sorry i had to double check something uh
all right
first things first james you'll need to raise the stairs to
the penthouse there's an access panel near the base it may
be offline I'll figure it out.
I didn't figure this out.
So you mentioned a plan Accessing the approach requires a
level 5 security.
Oh, turning the power back on after clearing those things.
Oh, that's why System reboot which will temporarily unlock
the gates and what do I do?
Go to the CCTV room.
No wonder there's no cameras I will infiltrate the mainframe
and trigger the procedure But I need the command code which
Sir Nicholas keeps in a safe in his office.
That's you James Okay, that makes more sense now.
The power's not on because I guess they have...
Because they gotta clean.
I work well on the pressure.
Alright.
Let's see.
Well, I mean, there's nobody here.
Power's off because everybody's cleaning.
Alright, power's back on now.
Cleaning done.
Okay.
Whoa.
Oh, this is not safe at all.
No handrails?
Oh, that's not OSHA.
No handrails.
Definitely very fancy insurance you have there.
Swanky.
could use a rug
that note you passed me I love workplace accidents yeah no
slippery floors I wrote a memory aid to recover the safe
code what is this was an exact diploma painting game model
diploma painting game model well nothing about you is easy
whoa android prototype oh nice it's like the the kung fu
android's
all right grab this i believe an explanation is due i wasn't
lying well i was mostly lying i was gonna say i heard about
his very slippery floors no clue what was in it but it had
sir I figured I could use you for blackmail.
Sadly, Damien's thugs beat me to it.
Damien confided in you.
His office was adjacent to mine.
It's in walls.
Oh, that's what I've had a heart condition.
It appears to me as a heart would pierce a smart medical to
monitor his blood pressure and takes a dose.
Oh, no.
Let's get a new heart.
He's rich enough for that.
That is an inauguration.
Big day.
Oh, she can't afford a security bride whose spearheaded the
privatization of six.
signet but condemning the double old program to the dustbin
of history he does though he has enough money to just get a
new heart it's called the rich rich people privilege fellas
I have lasers coming up
there's that guy that fucking like exchanges his blood with
his son so he could look younger.
Damien needs a bloody... Oh my god.
I have a friend whose dad is like really fucking rich.
I have a friend whose dad is really fucking rich and he
literally travels.
I don't remember where he travels to, but he travels to
Europe to do like stem, like to get like stem cells so he
could stay young.
I was like, what?
Yeah.
He's like, he basically does, I don't even know I don't even
know exactly the process, but like it's somewhere in Europe
and it's just like replacing his cells with stem cells To
like so that he could stay young
Some rich pit people shit like it's some like million like
he's a millionaire so Yeah, who's stem cells?
I'm pretty sure it's like those lab grown because you can
grow stem cells now Um, and it's like and you can grow stem
cells and you like basically it replaces their dying cells
at some point your cells will stop replicating and that's
how you get old and so he's replacing his dying cells with
newer younger cells and like yeah yeah the classic rich
people thing to do like
um why does he just replace it with nano machines it's
heavily redacted but seems to suggest that Damien committed
war crimes during his time as a private military contractor
in 2018 he and a small band of mercenaries were arrested
during a botched cooped detain attempt in central Africa or
constructed by a Dutch mining company Sir Nicholas must have
pulled some heavy favors to bury his son's antics and report
a scandal that will tarnish the family name of course the
people loads of might don't want to die and lose lose their
money dark thank you the super chat thank you thank you i
only knew about this because like his dad is like a super
alcoholic so he's like worried for his help which is
understandable you know and so like like he's so so he's
like oh i'm worried about you and he's like it's okay i i
went to europe and got stem cells like like what it's like i
can still be an alcoholic just Like, I just went to Europe
and got stem cells replaced.
Like, or he could stop drinking.
I don't know.
A pretty hard decision.
But, yeah.
Do I stop drinking or do I travel to Europe pay millions of
dollars to replace my cells?
I wonder which is smarter.
It's not.
Alright.
Let's see.
Well, I never know.
Has he tried to stop drinking?
Um, the guy...
Ahead of not one, but two noble laureates.
That's what I'm saying.
If he has a heart condition, just fucking buys a new...
A heart.
He can skip the weight.
list at that point this is not accurate i'm it's breaking my
immersion if he's so rich why doesn't he buy a new heart
like thank you thank you dad you need to stop drinking
you're going to die oh son oh son rich people don't die we
just steal the life force of orphans in europe all right
thank you with a super chat thank you thank you a copy of an
early 90s adventure game written and programmed by I want
Nicholas Webb, a dystopian, neon-soaked sci-fi adventure
titled Hyperion 9.
All right, here we go.
Let's go hack this guy's computer.
Nerd alert.
This is not a very secret button, not gonna lie.
For a tech genius.
Like a fucking tech genius.
Why would you just hide?
Why would you just place it in the drawer?
Like that.
Okay.
Electronic lock.
Four digit code.
Better check the note.
I don't think I saw a note.
Okay, there's the note.
Never mind.
All right.
Diploma painting game model was one...
Okay, nine painting model.
Why am I missing a painting in a model, apparently?
I looked at all the paintings.
I mean, that's one of them.
Is there another painting I didn't see?
Web industry site three in Hong Kong.
Okay, there.
That has to be this.
Very pointy.
All right, we got that.
Now we need to find the painting.
Fuck is the painting?
I did not see a painting anywhere.
See a lot of statues.
That's not a painting.
I'm sure his 13th heart transplant was...
Oh, there's the painting.
There we go.
Every techno-futurist was nightmare.
All right, we got everything.
All right.
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm...
island all right uh one four part of an a.m way ai generated
art oh okay just ai i didn't even notice that appears to be
oh yeah it was generated i like how you framed it too this
actual ai art all right let's see one okay diploma painting
game one four nine three one four nine three one four nine
three sir nicholas i couldn't have done it without you got
the safe open look for an eight letter word he's an ai bro i
mean his whole thing company is ai got it the command code
is basilisk you make a fine sidekick james now cover your
tracks and get ready activating the security override all
right cover my tracks i guess i pushed the jewelry back guys
watch this i'm an international spy i covered my tracks oh
shit right now i'll see you off just need something for my
desk oh careful james damian will kill you a as look at you
stay hidden and don't try anything this operation is
critical like it or not we're in the spotlight now pull one
thread and it all unravels bond try to get closer I'll use
the feed from your mic to try and record what they're saying
maybe we'll get lucky stay hidden move closer a bit of an
oxymoron what about our tenacious friend this may be hard
for someone like you to I deal with threats using
appropriate means and force but you left fingerprints
everywhere and what does the great sir Nicholas Webb fear
please enlighten me please hang in we've no room for
mistakes go to Vietnam and make it clean this time can you
handle that yes yes I get it Nam.
Hang on.
It's time for my meds.
Oh, time for the meds.
The voices are coming.
You, the epitome of calm.
Still waters run deep.
I mean, yeah.
I mean, as long as they touch everything I touch, it should
be fine, right?
I take it you are close.
We thought it like my condolences.
His brother's not taking me well.
This will get ugly.
I would expect so.
They take the meds?
Did I?
All right.
Did we get out of it?
We can't use it.
Oh, okay.
You only have four minutes.
You'll never make it.
Yes, you will.
I'll guide you.
Where do I go?
Just shut up and go.
Go where?
Hold on.
There's supposed to be an escape passage.
Look for a hidden switch.
Oh my god.
Web's desk.
Another hidden switch?
Oh my god.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Maybe it's the cat.
I found it.
It's the cat.
I knew it.
I was like, that cat's too big.
I'm out.
Where to?
In the security office, take the door on your right.
Okay.
Also locked.
Look for a vent.
According to schematics, it'll lead back to the exec floor.
There you go.
Alright.
Don't worry, guys.
I've done the escape room before.
I might have been carried, but I'd still escaped.
What do I do now?
You'll have a clear view of the gate.
Just one guy, right?
Hi.
Bet you didn't see that coming.
Nobody here?
Oh.
is there's an elevator at the end of the hallway hurry james
they don't know they don't know door it is go through the
vent then take the door on the left there's a vent oh dirt
uh yeah oh i have to breathe Breach it?
Okay, breach.
Okay.
I was like, I will vent not open.
Made it.
Don't stop now.
Continue down the hole.
Okay.
All right.
Left.
Is there anybody here?
You made me do.
There's stuff in here.
Much better.
You don't know.
Uh, uh, uh, open.
I'm through.
The elevator is down the hole to your right.
You can ride it all the way to the bridge.
All right.
Let it ride!
It's something good.
Not the left.
I'm not a moment too soon.
Get off.
Let it ride!
Oh shit!
Okay, all right.
It's fine.
It's fine Don't fuck one minute.
There we go
All right, we got that we're okay.
We're okay situation contained
It's all right Nothing to worry about
Oh, maybe I should have called the elevator before I started
beating people up.
Oh, why is this elevator so slow?
Come on.
Are you serious?
Come on, bye.
We're almost there.
Oh, God.
God, please open doors.
Whoa.
This is something.
The bridge is starting to retract.
You have 30 seconds.
I'm 30 seconds.
Oh, God.
It's fine.
James, above you, grab Oh, Tao, Tao, Tao.
Okay.
That's how.
Oh, I am going so fast.
I just think it was super chat.
Thank you.
We'll do it next week.
We'll just, this week was so, so much stuff to do.
Too many games to finish.
Well, it wasn't hard at all.
Too easy.
Money, penny, we're in.
Money, penny?
Don't bother.
The place is a giant Faraday cage.
Nothing goes in or out.
Oh, she tells us.
The evidence is here.
And we need access before they wipe the service.
Good luck with that, boys.
we should do this again sometime yeah quit 20 minutes in and
out she does that
nice coat where's mine I'm sure you'll think of something
yeah because I did so well last time please gather in the
ceiling fire suppression system possibly Yeah, it's casual
Friday.
I'll think about considering it.
What happens if I just punch her?
No, don't do it.
Don't let the thoughts win.
Hello.
You're late.
Got stuck in traffic.
Surprise, we made it at all.
You can join the degaussing team.
Come on through.
Not you.
Get your uniform first.
Company policy.
It's the middle of the night.
Oh, I was in the middle of the night.
Thank you.
You heard her.
Perch rules.
I'll wait upstairs.
Fine.
Good.
We have fun.
A jacket.
I don't know.
Company secrets, I expect.
The work we do, especially what comes out of R&D, is just
too valuable.
Come allow some new bureaucrats to walk away with hundreds
of millions of pounds worth of research.
No matter the reason.
Say, where's your lab coat?
Yeah, where is it?
I can't find the key.
I had it on the ride up, so it must be around here
somewhere.
As you dropped it, the cleaning robots will find it.
Those things will have anything in their paths.
We have to find the cleaning robot.
All right.
We just gotta find the robot.
Oh, there you go.
Call him.
Cleaning robot, where are you at?
Sorry, mate.
Service desk is closed.
I'm only here for the code.
Same as you.
I won't bother you.
Oh.
You can't really be here.
Sorry about that.
There's the cleaning robot.
There you are.
Oh, yo.
Do you have a key for me, little guy?
Get in here.
Oh, he's pooping.
Guys, let's watch.
Is that it?
Wait, what?
What?
Where's the key?
Oh, it's on the other side.
Oh All right.
Diarrhea time.
Go poop.
Now it's your turn time to poop
Oh, no.
Don't worry.
I hope the six Worth a visit.
Well, that's bizarre.
All right.
Nice.
We're going to grab some stuff here quick.
Sorry about that, buddy.
That felt off.
Alright, let's see.
Now that I have that, I'll go to the locker room.
I guess where is the locker room?
The smoking indoors become illegal anyway.
20 years ago, Jeremy.
Oh, there's the lockers.
Okay, locker six.
What have you got for me?
Alright, locker number six.
There it is.
Our Denny's stuff is not a joke, guys.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
He's gonna get fired soon.
So unfortunate.
Might lose his job for what I'm about to do.
All right.
Noink.
Mine now.
Look at that.
They both hit.
Well, job done.
All right.
Just now.
Oh, fuck.
Provide cover to enemy.
I'm through.
Join me in the control room.
We'll be able to access the data from here.
Pardon me?
Passing through.
It uses an electromagnetic pulse to realign the magnetic
elements on the chip support.
Wait.
Rendering the data impossible to recover.
I can't just leave that.
That's so dumb.
All right.
I don't care.
it just works guys it just works it just works I'm so smooth
wait where am I supposed to go I was supposed to go up I was
too distracted I was like whoo servers all right so I got a
little too distracted there wait what the fuck am I
what am i supposed to my vault oh i can't vault up okay guys
don't look don't look at the stairs guys don't look at the
stairs all the trainees are just like what are what jerry's
doing right now someone needs to bring them back on manually
lay it on me well first we must work out the procedure admin
unit over there.
See if you can't turn it back on.
Alright.
Just turn it back on.
Easy in and out.
You think they won't notice, right?
Nah, they're not gonna look to the left.
How's that?
50 eyes.
Watch the school as well.
Let's try something else.
Take it back offline and look for a manual override switch.
Manual override switch.
Alright.
They're interns.
They're not allowed to speak at...
So true.
Here we go.
Good.
Now put the server back online.
All right.
Fingers crossed.
Oh, is this guy playing video games right now?
What are you doing?
Now we repeat the process in the server room.
Scanning the search history for keywords.
What are you doing?
Over there.
Hey, guys.
I'll let you know when I find a match.
Alright.
Oh, I gotta do it in the other place.
Oh, am I not?
I'm not allowed up here.
I'm just a little intern.
Done.
Cluster 4000 is scrap metal.
You can start in this cluster as soon as Carl's taking them
off like.
We'll do.
Bon, I have three matches.
Servers.
1100.
2600 and 3200.
what are any of those copy that and remember to flip the
override switch oh that's 1100 able to access the data got
that it's not rocket science or carry on then before they
catch on wait that is 1100.
what the i beamed that but it didn't work
okay i won't work need the manual override first You think
they saw me?
You think they saw me there?
They clicked that whoops.
Whoops.
Identify yourself immediately.
No.
What happens if I...
Oh, whoops!
Oh no!
Someone shoot me!
No!
Shoot me right now!
Shoot me!
Oh shit!
Oh I should let him shot me!
Shoot me!
Yes shoot me!
Shoot me so I can arm!
Yes!
Wait!
What?
Okay.
It doesn't work like that apparently.
Oh!
It doesn't work like that.
Oh, shit.
It's okay.
It's not a gun.
I thought it was a gun.
No, God.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
It's
a kids ride.
Oh, my God.
Why won't anyone shoot me?
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
Mistakes are worth me.
All right.
Okay, now that we know...
Oh, shit.
Okay.
All right.
Only I got my leg.
Oh my god, I have to open it again
There's a manual lever Let's see Make him sick That'll be
fine, right?
That's fine Alright
You No, no, his eyes.
Not his eyes.
No.
Yeah, forget it.
Oh no.
How could that have happened to him?
Who did that?
Who could have done that?
Oh shit.
Okay.
Oh, who did that?
Oh, guess we'll never do.
Alright, it's fine.
Just maybe.
Yeah, what are you doing?
What are you doing down there?
Whoops.
Alright, nice.
It's just some bodies.
You know?
It's just such a shame.
All right.
Nice.
We got one.
Server 1100 is active.
All right.
Oh, hacking?
Oh, shit.
What's that over there?
Is that a body?
Sure.
Nah.
No time.
Okay.
And then...
Cat C!
Don't worry, he still can't see!
He's okay!
He still can't see!
Oh my god, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Come on!
Come on, you know you want it!
Get a little closer.
Oh, you're almost there.
You're almost there.
Oh shit, I thought, okay, dude, that was a little
anticlimactic.
That was...
That's a little anticlimactic.
Okay.
It's all right.
It still works.
It's... I thought it would land on...
All right, my little pile of bodies.
There we go.
One more body for the pile.
guys just so all right nice oh god there's so many people
i know right so weird what could that be what's that closer
closer there you go could that be i guess we'll never know i
do need more gadgets though Okay.
It's 1600.
Okay, the next one has to be, like, all the way over there
on the other side.
Alright.
Just move it.
Yeah.
So the plan is...
We blind this guy.
And then...
And then we do a takedown on him.
and then take him here oh dear oh there it is nice it was
right here i'll take him online oh whoa what's that 2600 is
back online good man download all right proceed to the next
server hey looks like a body in here oh my god bodies Where?
Okay.
All right, guys.
What we're going to do is that.
Zap!
No.
And then...
What's up with you?
What happened?
That's right.
Get down, Mr. President!
I'm my new pilot.
And then I created a new pile all right we need was it
thirty two hundred that should be the other side yeah the
thirty three hundreds are over there okay thirty three
hundred this is what number is that god where's the thirty
three hundred pile Is this 200?
Okay.
200, 500.
I'll never...
Yeah, that's the charging station, guys.
Alright, there we go.
Oh, this is a little awkward now, though.
Oh!
Oh my god, what could that be?
Leave it.
Leave it!
Huh?
Okay.
I mean, that works.
Oh, there's 30, 200.
Damn.
Sucks to be that guy.
And also that guy.
Alright.
Nice to know his life isn't valued here.
He's just, they're just like, oh, let's just leave it.
That's cool.
Not good.
Oh, yeah.
Apparently he's okay with those guys.
Oh.
He's alive.
Must be our guy.
Alright.
He's alive, though, at least.
all right it's fine just a little tragic work accident you
know yeah blind him real quick take online and then another
tragic work accident Accident 200 reactivated nicely done
all right Easy just another tragic work accident you say
What oh shit, he's expecting him to come over It's okay.
He's not gonna bring over anyway Is that a body
Hey, you okay there?
Oh, okay
Oh my god now there's two bodies bodies.
Is that another body on my body?
No, they're just really stupid.
They're multiplying.
Oh my god, mitosis.
Cellular division.
All right, we're done downloading.
Okay, I think we've got what we How?
Return to Greenway.
Oh my god.
I gotta retrace my path.
That's fine.
I know how to retrace it.
Identify yourself.
Come on, focus.
Knock it off.
You think I'm- Oh shit!
Don't!
It's okay!
Greenway is here!
Okay.
That's fine.
Greenway!
No!
After everything!
I was so smooth!
Oh god.
I'm so sad.
It was almost...
We were almost there.
Woo!
Okay, it's okay.
Take down.
I got... I literally got one guy.
Get that guy out of here.
Whoa!
Okay, it's fine.
I'll just do this.
Watch this.
It's okay.
Oh, watch this.
It works.
It just works.
Situation contained.
There we go.
Not bad.
Not bad at all.
We did it.
Mission reports.
Out.
Marley, 2019.
Karachi, 2021.
The drone strike on Z.
Sarazin, the arms dealer.
I thought that was a CIA.
So does the CIA.
Bunt.
What?
These are all MI6, Black Ops, based on confirmed data.
Yeah, I told you it's the AI computer.
Some of our biggest intelligence successes in the last
decade.
But if I'm reading this right, we were working off a false
intel every single time.
That's the inside job.
Bayer makes mistakes.
and the reason we don't know who would have thought AI makes
mistakes so it looks like every time Thayer gets her wires
crossed he dispatches Damien to fix the narrative to alter
crime scenes plan evidence frame or eliminate witnesses oh
correcting the facts to fit the data and this has been going
on all the way back to London 2014 Nightfall.
There was a lie right from the start.
I mean, we should have called it.
Thea drew a false conclusion, so Webb made it true.
Frame 009 and the others.
That's why they...
That's why I double...
Yeah.
I called it from the beginning.
I was like, there's no way.
Hey!
Greenway.
I mean, that's very topical with current AI.
James Bond.
You have a phone ahead.
That's why he's like trading.
You lied about everything.
You're not seeing the big picture.
It was like, you guys are tradies.
And they're like, what?
It takes a certain kind of mind.
Just wake up one day and Thea just fucking hates you.
Where is it for power?
Oh, no, no, I get it.
You sold out your values for power and profit.
Nothing new.
Did you know that every year, 1.35 million people are killed
in car accidents worldwide.
And yet, we just accept it.
Fact of life.
But if a single driverless car malfunctions, clear the front
page fascinating your point people are short-sighted they
have boundless patience for human stupid yeah okay but they
have made multiple like a lot of mistakes for like
international like international crime like it is broken of
course like that's not just a fucking driverless car it's
like an international political incident single isolated
incident again and again and you let it continue and then
the ai learns from doesn't like builds off of the mistake
thinking it's true the smartest mind on the planet it will
attain perfection and when it does the lies will no longer
matter but just like you and i faya learns it's learning to
become perfect it must be used but mi6 would never have let
me use it unless it already was perfect you see my
predicament oh i do and until reality catches up with your
lie everyone who gets never corrected framed discredited
that's what i'm saying they're not correcting it because
they're correcting it themselves they're not if it isn't
being told that they're up consequences of our actions but
as you yourself said we can't do nothing that's the biggest
sin of all enough you can rationalize it anywhere you want
you won't change your damn I changed things all the time.
I changed you, John.
I made him kill his friend.
I guess we'll never know.
Oh, shit, they're gonna gas.
Oh, now there's security, I guess.
Bond, step aside.
Then here, you'll need that.
oh all right how long till i die i can't see
follow the light
okay apparently bit near the door Use the...
Greenway!
Oh, it's over here.
Alright, there we go.
I got it.
Bon, do you copy?
Made it out.
Where are you?
For the flight deck.
There's a helicopter we can use to escape.
But you watch yourself.
It's reinforcements here.
Where the fuck did he go?
He didn't use the vent.
Thanks for the heads up.
Yeah, I was gonna say that was not near the door.
gonna say that's definitely not near the door
you're grabbing your gun i am now licensed to kill is he
okay give me a second
Worth it?
Yeah, I would say it was worth it.
There we go.
I had to kill him.
Thank God I'm not licensed.
I can't keep up this pressure forever.
Oh, he thinks I can't.
at.
I will absolutely keep up that pressure.
Coast is clear.
Gotta keep going.
Bond really thinks I wouldn't.
There's the others.
Oh.
Here you go.
I'm out of ammo, but that means I have to...
They're not another gun.
Okay.
oh still with us you won't get rid of me that easily oh now
you're not gonna pee i'm almost at the flight deck get here
as quick as you can oh my god little bitch oh shit
i need to get that goddamn sniper there you go now he's out
There we go.
Nice.
You were the only one left.
Okay, we'll grab the sniper.
Alright.
Easy.
Poor bullets.
They just keep on coming, don't they?
They do?
Oh shit, they do!
There we go.
Oh, I guess it is.
Where are you?
Oh, wait, that's not up to you.
There's more than one of you.
What do you mean?
Now it's only up to you.
There we go.
Oh, more people.
All right, it's fine.
What the fuck?
I like, they're like, use the missile pen.
Use it.
Oh, shit.
There we go.
We're okay.
Everything is fine.
There we go.
Just line it up for me.
Oh, nice.
Line up.
Line up your head.
There we go.
Thanks for lining your head for me.
Easy.
Next stop.
Cargo deck.
We gotta grab that.
I like that they lined up just for me.
Money Penny, if you're there, listen carefully.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, bud!
Money Penny, do you copy?
No!
Bud, why?
Why do you...
Oh my god.
No, don't tell me to do it all from the beginning.
No.
oh thank god okay not from the beginning at least that's
fine i could do it from here
he just had to vote oh my god that took like way too many
shots just push through
all right at least i gotta check for it which is nice it was
just unfortunate that he had to vote Oh.
Oh, reloading.
There we go.
All right.
Where's the last?
Where's the other guy?
Is he dead?
He just trips over a little bit upstairs.
That's fine.
All right, now that we know, now that we know not to vault.
He didn't.
Money penny.
If you're there, listen carefully.
It's worse than we imagine.
Webb is covering up there his mistakes and Damien is the key
to prove it.
All right, gravity is very dangerous.
It really is.
Just been there.
Yes, I can.
Bond doesn't know.
I can and I will.
That's right.
Sniper shotgun.
there you go i'm at the flight deck what's your status
popular as ever well hurry up i'm the place is crawling with
mercs if they spot me i'm done for all right we got another
gun all right it's fine i like how they gave me like a
shitload of gadgets and i'm like
They're like, you could do this?
You could do that?
I'm like, pew, pew, pew.
They just keep on coming, don't they?
Yeah, they do.
They're above.
Oh, they're in front of me, actually.
There you go.
They're shooting me.
Oh, they are.
All right, one more bullet here.
never gun there you go easy that all of them oh they're
above me but the red bear is dokey no we shoot who needs red
bearers when you have guns coast is clear gotta keep going
just how do I get down there down there that's why I was
asking how do I get down there I need to do something fast
oh shit it's fine I've just done there you go situation
contained how do I get there all right I've contained the
situation now how How do I get across?
Huh.
Killed everybody.
But now what do I do?
Well, I guess over from here.
Am I authorized personnel?
No.
Wait a minute.
Wait.
Mmm.
Look up?
I am looking up.
Reach the flight deck, but how?
Oh no.
How do I get to the other side?
Oh,
did I not have to beat these people up?
Is it all the way from here?
There's a door here.
This authorized person...
Oh no.
This is the hardest part of the video game.
Navigation.
Gamers don't look up.
I don't.
Unfortunately, that's not part of my vocabulary.
Yeah, we can vote this.
Are you looking up?
What does that mean?
Okay, that door opens.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Why does it want me to go up here?
Okay, now I'm up here.
Now I'm tall.
Greenway, please wait a second.
I'm lost, Greenway.
I'm lost.
How do I get across?
Oh.
Oh, right here.
I did it.
Of course, that's what this was for.
Oh, shit.
Error.
Weight imbalance detected.
Please vacate.
All right.
Make me.
So that's what it was for.
Greenway?
Where's Greenway?
Did
they not hear the gunshots from before?
Hey guys!
Evening fellas, is this the way to the rooftop bar?
No?
You hear that, Lawrence?
No man's thirsty.
Let's quench it for him.
license to kill oh shit oh shit oh shit okay watch this
though oh fuck that's that part not that part not that part
whoa all right watch this this will be my strat oh shit no
no no my strut oh no my strut all right it's okay it's okay
oh my god it's okay okay it's fine watch this though
There we go.
Boom!
Oh shit!
Oh, that's not cool.
That's not cool.
That's not cool!
There we go.
Oh shit, that's not cool at all.
Okay, but I do have the vault strapped up.
Oh my gosh.
Vault.
Vault!
Oh shit!
Alright, take down.
I told you, the vault strat.
I hit the spot.
There we go.
Guys, it works, guys.
It might took 20 attempts, but it works.
I told you.
Did you watch it?
and this is why i'm absolutely in street fighter greenway
i'm almost there talk to me this is why little foreshadowing
for my street fighter tournament later
uh this way
greenway bolt i'll hold up inside the helicopter i need you
to draw their attention while i raise the platform All
right, wouldn't it feel kind of weird that the door is
opening is the jump across from the control room and I won't
lie Wait, they have guns.
I'm ready The moment you break cover they'll shut the hangar
doors the lock.
Oh, okay.
Never mind go
Never mind I was gonna be I'm ready to shoot shoot the pipes
a pipe Where's the pipes?
Wait, where?
Oh.
Oh my god, there we go.
I got it.
Oh,
I am so hit.
Get to the control room.
I'm trying!
Maybe I'm not, actually.
I don't think I am.
I might not be trying.
Oh my god.
No, that's not what I want it.
I'm trying!
Oh my god.
If you
can't...
What the fuck?
I didn't mean to.
Alright, it's fine.
I have 40 seconds.
I can do this.
No!
I can...
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I got the wrong gun.
okay wait now I'm
trying okay oh my god
I'm trying to like get closer to the Oh, please stop.
Oh, fucking hell fucking course.
All right.
That's fine.
We're so safe
We're so safe I'm trying for real this time
Real for real
There's like 20 people shouldn't we there you go we're okay
jump it's not part of the plan there you go see i told you i
can do it i told you i was trying
just another day at the office
where are you going we need to finish this How are you
efficient?
You're right, Bond.
I couldn't have known, but I didn't even try.
I never even looked.
You're giving up.
He's too guilty.
There is no we.
He's filled with guilt because he killed his best friend.
It was doomed from the start.
Like doomed Yowie.
see they both lost their boyfriends
no time to die escape by helicopter that's me money penny we
need to round not here come on oh she just got back from her
date I mean it looked like a fun date girl it's too bad your
entire career was built on a lie but hey oh she didn't get
to smash too because I i interrupted her before they got
took before they went home unlucky losing her job and her
date no smashing for you
i looped the security feeds in the lobby in the elevator you
don't have a lot of time she got dokey blocked yeah wiping
everything at webhq we need to send a team over there right
now look it's not that simple james what we messed up going
to webs You don't do a thing like that without consequence
consequences for web here's a very powerful man.
What's wrong with everyone first greenway now you For
greenway, this is a whole different game.
Hey, for one be surprised.
This is a private company changes everything for him Well,
not private, you know, I mean, but like it's like semi
funded by greenway changed the rules Where are we going
you'll see Did no one just order coffee on this machine?
Chief?
Could do with a cup.
No.
Okay.
We call it the null space.
Whatever goes on in here never happened.
No surveillance, not on any blueprints.
It doesn't exist.
If you hope to bury this, you're out of luck.
I don't care who Webb is.
We need to stop him.
What we do is not up to us anymore, Bond.
Is this M stalling?
Where is she?
I'll talk some sense into her.
Be careful what you wish for.
I don't think it was super chat thinking, thank you.
Maybe it will be a bad idea if I got a girlfriend.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, hey, M.
M?
Thank God we've done a much time.
There's been a development.
Sir Nicholas Webb sent me this.
In case you're wondering, it is footage of you and Greenway
assaulting Web HQ.
Two of my agents rogue on British soil.
Well, that doesn't change the fact that...
It changes everything.
He is accusing you of terrorism.
He CC'd half the cabinet.
As we speak, there are arrest orders with your names on
them, working their way through the system, and my future's
not looking much brighter.
We just have to show them what we found.
Oh, God, don't be so naive.
It's one thing that you broke into WebHQ.
It's another that you got caught, but leaving without proof,
you couldn't have botched this any worse had you tried.
What's wrong with the sound?
Of course I'm not.
What's wrong with the voice acting for her?
To collect the irrefutable proof we need to bring down the
web.
did i am putting a lot of trust in you don't you dare
disappoint me money penny go and finish the mission brief
bond you go and cq you're dismissed is
she an ai yeah i was gonna say straight it sounds like she's
like half ai or some like what's going on with her voice
it's obviously compromised this mission is strictly off the
record so you can't use it anymore It's just her.
It's like weird.
And then what?
Mem needs to play her part and aid in apprehending her rogue
agents.
And Thayer will assist.
Yes.
However, I'm taking a few pages out of 009's playbook.
I've already set up hundreds of breadcrumb trails for rogue
agent James Bond on the run.
That should buy us some time.
Meanwhile, you, Mr. Sinjin Smythe, do what billionaire
playboys do best.
The trip booked a year ago.
No one will suspect a thing.
All right.
I am.
I think it's just...
It's definitely the...
The time of the year.
But Bonnie's just not used to it.
It's been way too long.
According to his social media, Sinjin Smythe was really
looking forward to his stay.
But unfortunately for him, he bears a striking resemblance
to you.
And some odd mix-up with the permit for his private jet is
now delaying his takeoff.
dare say he will stay grounded until you send word it's safe
to clear up this misunderstanding the pearl my body's
playing catch-up right now without seya you're in for some
good old-fashioned spy work all right yay back to our roots
all right before ai we're gonna do it before ai was a thing
just like the good old days the classic bond adventures hey
there you know like these roads some of these robots are
used to make coffee i've seen that in korea some of them are
just coffee makers
thank you i say great work at web industries or pizza well
the whole business is dreadful of course but silver lining
finally some real failure is not an option spy word living
by one's wits no safety net gets the blood flowing no right
not speaking of silver linings nice try but you won't need a
car where you're going besides she's not ready i do have
some gadgets lined up for you though make a gander oh and
water's left you a new service pistol and a suppressor just
in case Try not to lose it this time.
You know how it is, Q.
Easy come, easy go.
All right.
Pick up the suppressed pistol.
Where did he...
Oh, it's all the way on over there.
Like how they're...
Oh, I was going to say, are they doing it over the...
Why do they need a cover if they're just going to modify it?
All right.
I feel like...
I'm going to have more than one now.
Oh, I can finally...
Uh...
I mean, I can't really change any of my stuff.
Okay.
You should take good care of us, Q.
All right, got my suppressed pistol.
Is this Doki Bird?
No.
Q, I've been meaning to ask.
I'm Brokey Bird.
I'm no expert, but I believe it's a probability paradox.
When one has a large enough data, set accidental patterns
emerge from the chaos coincidences that appear deliberate
random events that seem meaningful if enough people slip on
banana peels it starts to look like banana peels are out to
get us spot on so no resemblance at all exactly genius and
madness um present company excluded of course of course how
did we not realize that web was covering up there's mistakes
bias, I suppose.
We saw what we expected to see.
Thayer was supposed to be infallible, so no one searched too
hard for evidence to the contrary.
Thayer made us complacent and risk averse.
Oh, just like AI!
You really are a glass half full person, aren't you?
Well, you would think that Q would at least be like, hmm,
that's weird.
Like...
You have a lock on Greenway.
He was in a rough spot.
If anything, you would think Q would have been like, huh?
If he doesn't want to be found, There's not much we can do
about it.
Look, Greenway has had the rug pulled from under him.
Give him some space.
I'm ready to go.
Ready to head out.
Front gates too risky.
Wait, you'd be like, hmm, that's weird.
I should, like, you know, we got peer review.
Let me get the door for you.
There.
It's right through the wind tunnel.
Just watch out for the Bakerloo line.
Don't be kidding.
Right.
Good luck, Bond.
one guy checking his work all right secret data so tell me
james are you familiar with the scientist benjamin kwan oh
she's not even gonna all right oh there it is i think some
kind of green energy pioneer full marks neutrino voltaic
energy research sadly he died last month in singapore under
Ambiguous circumstances.
Oh, too real.
Oh, shit.
Wait, that's just like what's going on right now.
Wait, this was written before...
This was written before the weird scientist murders in
America.
That's awkward.
That's what a coincidence.
The scheme was done before the...
The weird scientist deaths.
got to do with web here's the kicker according to interpol
caliban's what timing were recovered from a mexican landfill
and according to forensics he's been dead for months now if
this is true it means that they have made another blunder
another ghost pattern yes oh they up again damien is in
vietnam to cover up this latest mistake likely he planned
how many mistakes how many mistakes original conclusion He's
pretending that he's still alive.
That's crazy.
He's up to you.
All right, we're here now.
This is where the famous TikToker is.
All right, we're in Vietnam now.
Oh, it's so pretty.
This is a long ass river.
All right, time for a little Q&A.
Who are we playing today, James?
Smythe.
Sinjin Smythe.
And what do we do for work?
We run our own company.
A same-day courier service called Go Get It.
Launched it a year after turning our back on the music
business.
Why would we do such a thing?
Too many arseholes and egos.
Lovely.
And Vietnam?
Once a year, we hop on a plane and venture somewhere to
recharge our creative juices.
This year, when the dice rolled, Vietnam came in.
up okay i buy it that's because i'm selling it so well i'm
such a good spy time to die guys how many chapters are there
and the welcoming committee time to get in character whoops
sorry that's a strong-ass fucking boat
oh wait i created uber eats
two more i think we could finish this next stream i just
want to reach the island before Oh, the last three are
logged.
Never mind.
I think I can.
I think I can finish it in one stream.
The staff and I are very pleased to have you with us.
This way, sir.
You smarmy get...
I didn't call it here.
Well, you are a natural, James.
That's Mr. Smarmy to you, my dear.
I'm going to call it here.
just because like after this cutscene just because fatigue
is hitting me hard right now and I do have a collab later
today so alright we're calling here I have a collab later
tonight at 11 p.m.
I wish I could play more but I'm so fucking tired right now
alright guys let me see my energy for collab collab requires
more energy and I also have a convention to my own panel and
meet and greet I assume it's just I assume it's a Q&A
usually that's what I do for panelists um but I'll see you
guys next time everybody I'm gonna go take a nap before my
collab as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get
up and move around to get that blood flowing uh definitely
flowing if I'm sorry I'm there and you stand for me head to
bed because you deserve it I'll see you guys next time
everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.